a gondola like in the yeah I think you
guys need to fight this out okay
[Applause]
universe to me I'm close I'll guard
that will we will see yeah Oh will you
organic yes this place is nice welcome
to my house oh my crib mr. Pratt how do
we get in all right
you break a window Jack this is now your
place you're lying to us replace the
windows you're trying to look cool we
understand
I'm not so I'm always cool I don't need
to look unlock the door open no that guy
coming around trying to steal all my
[ __ ] as always Hey all right okay you're
it's okay I'm gonna break all your [ __ ]
[Music]
crazy sailor motel Bob's the murderer by
the way it's like it's like I told you
Bob is the murder not the murderer he's
mark not dad what happened
oh boy you you wouldn't hit a guy who
can't see was it what you can't see why
not
did you shoot someone I shot own i
capable kind to see it okay people bed
yes
down there Bob Lyon forgotten anymore
yeah I'm gonna ask you one question
what's your favorite color
yeah it's gonna say push them off flip
but then I realized Owen will want that
I'll do it dude I killed in a tragic
accident on the roof yeah everyone just
jumped I can't believe it's crazy do you
have the gun jacker I do
Irish justice yeah exactly a kneecap for
a kneecap what I used to call my pools
ah are you trying to kill yourself it is
by the museum you gotta go towards like
the water's edge towards the Sun oh yeah
okay right behind you guys I'm right
behind you well ten Jack I brought you a
table for your home I brought you a
chair oh that's a that's a that's a
federal offense oh I don't he's innocent
mr. mr. president he's totally answered
you just seem you want me to kill him
yes okay so your last word Jackie pretty
sure I've got a good ridged I had to
kill you because I'm turned around why'd
you have to turn around I couldn't shoot
you right in the face it's heartbreaking
I was hoping to make a guilty I'd was
yes why you can come by give us your
offering I'm trying to find a good gift
I got the party lights glow sticks right
here hang on
I bought him just cuz I was at the store
guys damn it I'm Raven here with actual
glow sticks oh yeah
are you putting go sticks in your mouth
[Laughter]
I'm turning out of the light marks
Chokin
[Music]
you you didn't have ghosts in your mouth
you and your stupid impossible let's
blow six for it if possible let's play
hang on
you shouldn't drink oh my hear that
candy don't put don't put him up your
ass whatever you do that is the trip to
the hospital you don't worry not so mark
how you feeling go go you start taste
great you better hope they don't crack
it I know it's gonna burst no no I got
all our cash all right you know what
forget your presents forget your
presents god I just drive my castings oh
hello my dance yeah mark I like your
dance that's cool keep doing that okay
hang on I gotta put them back in my
mouth really you have three seconds to
start or you get it in the face bark so
who is Juliette I am Juliette I'm
putting on my glow sticks oh my god all
right so where's the party going on over
here are you where are you Marty Park
the party fell off party I go see a
doctor about no the party's coming guys
just just wait do you like my party you
don't have a flashlight you just have a
glowing hand you're like the Iron Man
gotta make fun of my party blocking for
you I'll hold them in
thank you point-blank very hard
oh hey hey hey do you want to do you
want to do back - yeah okay like five
pages and then yeah okay pistols at dawn
okay ready all ready one two three four
five
[Laughter]
[Music]